the opening scene takes place in the
year 1944 amidst the Second World War
Two fighter pilots Hank Marlowe from the
United States and gunpai ikari from
Japan land on a South Pacific island via
parachutes as soon as they land they
begin to shoot at each other when they
run out of bullets Hank makes a run and
gunpai begins pursuing him soon they
reach a cliff where they engage in close
combat however their fight is soon
disrupted by the sudden appearance of a
giant ape what's up you little dildos
the scene then cuts to 1973 and we are
introduced to the head of the U.S
governmental organization Monarch named
Bill Randa and a geologist named Houston
Brooks who arrive at Senator Willis's
office the two proposed their plan of
exploring the newly discovered Skull
Island in search of prehistoric
creatures when Willis hesitates Bill
explains that the 1954 nuclear tests
weren't tasked but instead they were
trying to destroy something there
hinting at an unusual ecosystem despite
this Willis doesn't appear to be keen on
the idea and starts walking away however
Bill and Houston follow him emphasizing
the Island's potential value and the
need to prevent other nations from
taking the lead when they talk about the
Soviet Union Senator Willis finally
grants them permission if we don't do it
someone else will is the most tragic bit
of logic the human species has ever
created bill is then given the task to
assemble a U.S army unit under
Lieutenant Colonel Preston Packard's
command afterwards Bill and Houston
traveled to Saigon to hire a former
British Special Air Service Captain
named James Conrad as their tracker for
this Mission they meet him at a local
bar and provide a brief overview of
their mission along with a monetary
offer hearing this James demands more
money pointing out the life-threatening
dangers that involve rain heat mud giant
monkeys maybe I don't know but probably
maybe disease-carrying flies and more
the two agree to fulfill his demands as
there's no one better for this position
than James next bill also hires an anti
War photographer named Mason Weaver with
everyone on board the Ship Sails towards
its destination on their way a NASA
official named Victor Neves explains
that the Kong Skull Island is surrounded
by a Perpetual storm system which is why
it is secluded from the external world
he hopes they can go through it with the
help of Preston's military helicopters
additionally Victor introduces the
assembled team to Bill Houston and
another scientist named San Lin
continuing the briefing a military
service man named Jack Chapman informs
them that the persistent storm will
disrupt their communication which might
cause them to separate as a result he
sets a meet-up location on the Island's
Northern tip with the intention of
regrouping there within three days boy
we're sure meeting a lot of characters I
wonder if some of them will die as they
approach the island they notice a huge
storm with black clouds which they have
to pass through despite this extreme
weather the team opts to push forward so
everyone boards the helicopters and sets
off the situation gets intense as they
enter the storm causing the helicopters
to experience dangerous turbulence but
for fortunately they pass through it and
reach the island which appears to be
absolutely stunning shortly after the
soldiers start dropping seismic
explosives in order to map out the
island and prove Houston's hollow Earth
theory that's not Hollow you idiots it's
flat everything seems to be going well
until the team gets attacked by the
giant Ape from the opening scene he is
none other than Kong the mythical Beast
the soldiers respond with gunfire but
the bullets appear ineffective against
this Mighty creature in retaliation Kong
knocks down all the helicopters one
after another scattering the survivors
across the island following this two
groups form among the survivors one with
James Mason Victor Houston sanlan and a
soldier named slivico and the other with
Preston bill and the soldiers including
coal Mills and Woodward in the aftermath
Preston tries to establish contact with
his troops but only Jack manages to
provide him with his location before the
signal dies in the next scene an enraged
Preston confronts bill at gunpoint
demanding an explanation for the actual
mode of their expedition in response
Bill reveals that several decades ago he
and his family were traveling in the sea
when a mythical creature destroyed their
boat only he managed to survive but the
government claimed that the accident was
due to Mechanical failure since then
bill has made it his mission to prove
the existence of these monsters and
that's why he has led the team here
following this Preston and his group set
out towards Jack's location as they walk
through the forest a bamboo tree pierces
one of the soldiers mouths the next
second a colossal spider-like creature
shows itself and grabs one of the
comrades when it is about to eat him up
the soldier strategically cuts off his
Limbs and drops to the ground after this
the others opened fire on the creature
and eventually take its head off on the
other hand James leads his group towards
the Rendezvous Point amid their Journey
they attempted to contact the other
survivors via radio signal but it proves
fruitless while passing by a lake the
group encounters a massive buffalo-like
creature causing them to panic however
James analyzes the situation and asks
the team to stay calm he knows that the
creature doesn't want to harm them how I
don't know his intuition though turns
out to be true as the Beast turns away
and leaves continuing their Journey the
team comes across a place where they are
cornered by the local ewe natives who
bring out their weapons just before a
fight ensues Hank who is still alive
shows up he assures both parties that
they aren't a threat to each other after
this the natives invite the group to a
secure settlement once there Hank
explains to the group that he's been
here for the last 28 years and has
learned a lot about the natives and the
island according to him Kong is almost
like a god to the island because he has
been protecting them from predators
including a race of subterranean
reptilian creatures called skull
crawlers they were the ones who killed
his Japanese best friend gunpei he goes
on to say that Khan can easily handle
the young skull crawlers but the biggest
one is dangerous as it even killed his
family he implies that if anything
happens to Kong the skull crawlers will
dominate The Island after hearing all of
this James changes the subject let's
talk about football dude you've been
here for too long and tells Hank that
the rescue team will arrive in the
northern part of the island within three
days Hank however believes that it's
impossible for them to reach the North
in such a short time following this he
leads the group to a boat made by him
and gunpei prior to the latter's passing
since the boat needs some more
refinement they opt to complete its
construction so that it can take them to
the northern side in their desired time
the team members initiate work on the
boat except for Mason who engages with
the natives later on Mason hears a sound
coming from the other side of the wall
upon checking she finds a buffalo-like
creature trapped beneath a crashed plane
she tries lifting it up to free the
Buffalo but her strength isn't enough at
that moment Kong suddenly shows up and
tosses the plane aside releasing the
stuck creature he then momentarily
stares at Mason and then leaves
seemingly acknowledging her
compassionate act or at least her
boobous elsewhere Jack continues his
attempt to communicate with the colonel
but fails he then sits on a big tree
trunk to rest but it moves revealing
that it's no tree but a creature
startled Jack opens fire forcing the
creature to retreat unfortunate the
sound of the gunshots attracts a skull
crawler who finishes him off brutally as
Knight descends Jaime's group continues
their efforts on the boat amidst this
Mason tries to click some pictures of
northern light but her flashlight seems
to be damaged when James sees her
struggling he offers her as lighter a
Memento from his father he carried it in
his ass for 10 years by the following
morning the boat is finally ready to go
Hank retrieves gun pays sword from his
grave bids farewell to the natives and
they all ride down the river while
sailing Hank opens up to the group about
his family expressing his dream to
reunite with them a short while later
they regain their radio signal and are
able to hear Preston's voice they ask
the colonel to shoot a flare gun
pinpointing their location spotting the
Flare's illumination the group steers
their boat towards the source excitedly
however their happiness is short-lived
to when Victor is suddenly taken away
and torn apart by a horde of carnivorous
Birds the sinus heartbreaking but
despite this the group decides to
continue their journey toward the
remaining team members after a while
they get off the boat and walk into to
the woods where they regroup with
Preston with this reunion James proposes
that everyone board the boat to leave
for the northern side however the
colonel refuses and insists on searching
for Jack on the West Side Hank rejects
the idea because the west side is where
the skull crawlers live but the colonel
says the west side is where Tupac lives
but James reluctantly agrees Zhang he
was brought here as a Tracker he puts
forward one condition though that they
have to return back before nightfall in
the next scene Hank leads the group into
a forbidden zone which is a former
Battleground between Kong's ancestors
and the skull crawlers despite Hank's
objection Preston orders them to cross
it as they move through a sudden
Onslaught from a skull crawler compels
them to take cover behind the giant
bonds the skull crawler comes near those
bones and vomits a skull with Jack's tag
on it once the area grows silent the
group Ventures forward believing that
the creature has departed however their
assumption is proven wrong when it
returns and eats billup in retaliation
the group unleashes a barrage of gunfire
but the bullets are incapable of causing
much damage to the formidable creature
as a result the soldiers use machine gun
and flamethrowers against it to make the
situation even worse they're also
attacked by a wave of carnivorous birds
in the midst of this commotion slivko is
hit by the skull crawler causing the
toxic gas canisters in his possession to
detonate Hank after killing several
Birds passes the sword to James who then
goes to rescue slivko taking out all the
birds on his way he manages to get
slifco but the skull crawler shows up in
front of them just when it appears that
they're going to be killed Mason throws
James's lighter inside the creature
blowing it up in the aftermath Preston
still urges them to continue their
search in response James brings out
Jack's tag disclosing that he's no more
however the colonel remains Resolute as
he is determined to reach the crash site
and retrieve ammunition stash so that
they can kill Kong and Avenge the
soldier's death despite efforts from
Hank Houston and Mason to convey the
repercussions of killing Kong and the
subsequent unleashing of the skull
crawlers Preston doesn't change his mind
with no options left James discloses the
crash site's location to Preston
allowing his group to proceed there
while the others returned to the boat
that night Preston gathers explosives
from the crash site and sets up a trap
for Kong meanwhile James and Mason make
their way to a cliff in order to
ascertain the direction of the river
leading northward during this Kong shows
up before them but doesn't attack them
Mason steps forward to touch him gently
signifying their friendship but Kong
ain't no friend zone just then
Kong detects the detonation set off by
Preston's team prompting him to advance
in that direction James and Mason also
realize that their giant friend is in
danger so along with Hank they decide to
save him as soon as Kong approaches
Preston's team the colonel sets the
entire pond on fire attempting to burn
him the giant gorilla tries to fight
back taking at several soldiers but it
soon collapses to the ground Preston
then orders the remaining soldiers to
prepare the explosives to blow Kong up
however before they can do so James
Mason and Hank arrive at the scene and
hold them at gunpoint telling them to
back off they try to convince the
soldiers that they need Kong to keep the
skull crawlers out after a tense
standoff the other soldiers turn against
their Colonel but Preston remains
adamant just then the largest skull
crawler bursts out of the ground forcing
the group to run Preston stays behind to
trigger the explosives but before he can
do so Kong awakens and crushes him the
injured Beast then starts fighting
against the enormous skull crawler but
it struggles to keep up meanwhile the
group flees toward the shoreline James
instructs Mason to reach a cliff and
launch a flare so that Houston and the
team can locate them until then the rest
of them keep running only to be ambushed
by the skull crawler at one point Cole
decides to sacrifice himself for the
sake of his team's life so he unpins the
grenades and stands in front of the
creature however his sacrifice goes in
vain as the creature throws him away
with its tail as the skull crawler is
about to attack the group Kong reappears
sparking a fierce battle between the two
huge creatures Kong does everything he
can to overpower the skull crawler but
the latter eventually throws him away
causing him to get stuck on some chains
the skull crawler then proceeds to kill
Kong but in the nick of time Houston and
the group arrive with their boat and
open fire on it Mason also fires a flare
towards the creature distracting it long
enough for Kong to break free Kong
retaliates by hurling the skull crawler
into a cliff accidentally causing Mason
to plummet into the water reacting
swiftly Kong saves her but the skull
crawler grabs his arm with its long
tongue this proves to be the perfect
opportunity for our Beast as with his
immense power he rips out the creature's
guts finally killing it Kong then places
Mason down next to James before leaving
in the aftermath of these events the
survivors reached the Rendezvous point
and leave the island as Kong stoically
watches the movie ends on an emotional
note as Hank finally reunites with his
family after several decades you're
still single right honey
um
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching